so first off I just want to say
um very excited to speak with you again
we chatted for everything everywhere
um when you guys were doing the Press
tour and I just want to congratulate you
on your Oscar I know it's late but you
know is that what you just wanted to say
that
um so for american-born Chinese you are
playing an iconic mythological figure I
think myself and many Asians know the
name guanyin what was it like
um embodying the character and bringing
her into this like modern setting
because we get to see her you know not
just in purple regalia right right
um it is a real privilege and you know
it's an honor to be able to play her
first of all because you know she
embodies so many
all the goodness that we can think of
right to be to be able to say
I play Guan Yin then people will think
oh my God she has kindness she has love
she has Serenity she is you know because
that is what Kuan Yin does for us and
um but the fun part I must say
coming out in her full regalia was easy
because Joy question and Jose who did
the costumes really went out of their
way with the head the headgear and the
way the ropes float when as she's coming
down and with the wind
um but to bring her to the 21st century
that was when we had a little bit more
fun and but with great respect to who
this iconic goddess is
it was nice to see her like blending
right without it so the hoodie the
baseball cap so you would look and say
oh that's a nice Auntie or that's a you
know someone who's going shopping and
you know doing the groceries and things
like that and she would not stick out
like a sore thumb in that way uh so I we
really I really enjoyed that part of it
to give her a sense of playfulness
but not you know without uh overstepping
the line yeah definitely I mean I loved
seeing her at the buffet which I was
like oh this is definitely something my
family right it's like don't stop
yourself with the rice I love a Calvin
and the you know I was uh our writers
they were amazing when they wrote all
that into it and you go like oh my God
that's really funny because people were
will relate to that and it's coming from
the goddess of Mercy
that sense of humor is something which
which is I really enjoyed when it's not
too much in your face but it's there and
the underlying messages that comes out
with it's very very important and what
Drew you to this project other than of
course playing a goddess what uh the
story that it was telling you know the
story of coming of age for
um finding yourself worth not just as
the the teenagers the kids but also as
adults that you do not become bitter and
you think I'm doing this for everybody
except for me and to understand that
that the journey is hard
um acceptance
the most important thing is the journey
within yourself the spiritual side the
the love if you don't feel love for
yourself how would you expect somebody
else to love you if you can't even you
know first do it for yourself
um I think this whole part of the
identity who am I
who are you only you can answer that
question and I think a lot of the times
is perhaps we overthink things you are
Chinese and yes you are American and you
have such a Heritage that you can be
proud of and
learn and share with you know it's it's
never too late to learn
um and I think with the American Born
Chinese that's what it is doing is
giving you such a fun platform to learn
so many things about a different culture
maybe your own culture
um about the history about certain
mythological characters uh that are so
dynamic
interesting and bringing the Two Worlds
like that together
is is exciting so yeah for sure I mean I
I really enjoy the story of American
Born Chinese and I really like the fact
that this show is seeming seems to be
reuniting you uh reuniting you with your
everything everywhere co-stars but also
with like some Shang Chi people as well
what was it like um reuniting with you
know like getting to have scenes with
like key and with Stephanie obviously
you didn't have any scenes with James I
don't think but it was still like oh
there he is like it was nice sleeping
there oh yes I did have a scene with him
because we were all in the heavens oh
right yeah right yeah so you know being
reunited with the people that you've
worked with especially that you have so
much love for is always great and to
come together for such an important
story to be told is even better right
and we we all have roles to to play to
tell this story and um reuniting not
just in front of the camera but behind
the camera with uh destined and joy the
questions you know it was it was a dream
come true and also you know working for
the first time with Daniel Wu who plays
The Monkey King you know we've known
each other since the days in Hong Kong
where we were fighting and things like
that but we never had a chance to work
together uh so this time when he called
he texts me and he says are you on this
american-born Chinese I says yes and you
better get your in there as quick as
possible so it was a really really
tremendous uh opportunity and I'm so
grateful to for to Destin for calling me
and Melvin and Kelvin you know for
making it all come together and together
with Disney plus and this all happened
even before the Oscars that they knew
that these kind of stories have to be
told and we're one of the first few to
come out with
the American ball Chinese yeah I mean
this story was very relatable for me on
many levels I mean I am also American
Born Chinese
um but I didn't know that you and Daniel
had like worked together before which I
think that makes the like the
relationship that your two characters
have even better on like up you know
behind the scenes level at least yeah
um so you've been in so many franchises
lately you know we're in Marvel Star
Trek Witcher you're gonna be an avatar
you're gonna be in Transformers do you
have a big takeaway when it comes to
being in these types of projects has
there been like a lesson in all this or
is it just like you know you'll take the
jobs that come to you no no I think it's
very I choose the jobs that come to me
because it takes me away from my family
so I'm not going to do something that is
not meaningful to me so there's always a
reason why did I choose to do uh this
franchise or that franchise why did I
choose to but it was a choice it didn't
just you I'm you know fortunately I
think we're all in that we're in that
position where we the hardest thing is
sometimes to say no especially it could
be a a filmmaker or a Storyteller that
you really really want to work with but
that character just doesn't speak to you
or the story is not what you're looking
to do I think that is very important
um that I've
I try to do as best as not to play the
same characters again because then there
would not be educational for me as an
actor it would not be interesting to you
as an audience because you see okay
that's Michelle doing the Michelle thing
again
and I hope I'm always going to surprise
you or um give you yeah something
to think about so
that's why I take all these very
weird and wonderful and wacky roles well
we love to see you in all those roles
every time you appear I'm very happy to
see you oh thank you
yeah thank you so much for uh for taking
the time to speak with me and I just you
know I can't wait for everybody to see
this but I always love seeing you in any
of your projects so I can't wait for all
the other things to come in the future
thank you